on se connaît je m'appelle droit gueule
je suis le père de shannon la copine de
johnny je suis la mère de jamie on adore
shannon
je trouve que ce que vous faites c'est
vraiment intéressant qui veut investir
dont wmv on transfert des fonds
invisible dans des marchés invisible à
des vitesses invisible le minimum est de
300 300 milles riz qui ne laisse que
rien n'a rien pas vrai on s'en sortira
comme on l'a toujours fait
je rentrais chez moi oui sur les
chercher
je veux bien te conduit en état
d'ivresse hier soir j'en sais rien il ya
quelqu'un qui l'a ramené après la fête
qui ça de toute évidence c'est jimmy qui
était au volant de la jeep
la question c'est qui va avoir des
ennuis maintenant lui ou toi la valeur
de son investissement abc qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est dans l'ordre naturel des
choses
je suis pas fait pour ça couine
il faut que je récupère mon argent il
fout le camp de ma propriété
on doit tous faire des sacrifices mais
je ne peux pas être mêlés une espèce de
conspiration
alors tu as fini par fuguer j'avais
juste envie de te voir avant
vous voulez quoi je peux vous fournir
des informations qui sauveront votre
fils nous avons un témoin
directive
gratuit
bref
il faut que je récupère mon argent c'est
pas un jeu de roues pour toi c'est aux
organes plus circuler même modèle depuis
des mois la bbc
[Musique]